Justin you've made now two features that
have both received distribution do you
have any information that most
filmmakers don't have on securing a
distribution deal do you have any tips I
wish I did I think the one for an
independent film getting in front of an
audience and getting it reviewed by some
of the tastemakers and I think the best
tunnel for that to happen is through
through going to festivals and film
festivals so if you want to go back to
before I made features I made short
films and my final short film that I
made at UCLA film school got to play
festivals all over the country and I
made relationships with festivals that
way so that when I had a future I was a
known quantity or at least a more known
quantity than say someone who didn't
have any connections in the or or
relationships in the film festival world
that said the film festivals select the
films based on whether they liked you
not whether they like you but whether
they liked the film it just does help
though to get it in front of the right
decision makers sometimes if you know
them already which is not to say that it
gets you in but it gives you a better
chance because you know that if you have
spent a year or two years playing film
festivals with a short film they
recognize your name and then you can
contact them and say hey just just in
case you miss it try to look for this
movie then you have an advocate at that
film festival I'm not I'm not saying
that that's the only thing that but that
makes makes it you got in but it does
help because there's just every year
more and more films being made anything
that you can do to put your film on the
top of the stack of the ones they need
to watch is obviously to your advantage
as far as distribution goes I'm hopeful
that there's more festivals every year
where people will be buying films but
right now at you know in the United
States there's very few there's Sundance
there's you if you count Toronto North
America
and then there's South by Southwest
Tribeca maybe even Los Angeles Film
Festival I hope that every year it will
grow the number of festivals where films
are bought and and put into distribution
because that only helps the independent
filmmaker to have more options of places
to premiere their movie so I'm hopeful
that every year there's more but that
that is really the way that that I think
right now the system and the industry
facilitates a distributor that and good
reviews
you